hello everybody and welcome to part
six of our natural language toolkit with
python for natural language processing
tutorial video series
in this video we're going to be talking
about chinking so in the last video we
talked about
chunking now what is chinking
it's not really separate from a chunk it
is part of the same
thing actually they're not different so
you change something
from a chunk okay so what is chinking
it's the removal of
something so uh so sometimes you're
gonna find that as you're building these
chunks you're gonna be like i want this
and this and this
this this and this and this and then
before you know it you've basically
chunked everything except for like
one thing so so you can go the other way
and you can actually
say you want to chunk everything except
for something
okay so let's see how that might work
so we've got chunks here let us
to make things really simple we're going
to change this chunk
and this this new trunk will basically
be
a period asterisk
and that should be enough actually so
anything
and then zero more repetition so this
basically means we want a chunk and then
oh yeah
uh we'll do that so one or more of just
anything
okay so this will chunk everything
then we do a [ __ ] that we want to do so
we'll
hit enter
and then you begin the chain and the way
that we kind of denote that
is like opposite signs
like you've got like open and closed
curly braces the way you define like a
[ __ ] is going to be
a close open okay so
now what do we want to keep out of our
chunk
well we could start by keeping out any
um
verb okay so that
any verb or
preposition or whoops or
those uh was that i forget i still
forget determiner there we go
or um
that's good enough we'll do that for now
and then uh
basically one or more any more of these
so this is just
any of this uh get rid of so let's try
that chunk
or well chunk with the chain
yeah so these first few are basically
worthless so let's get all the way to
applause
okay so as you can see our chunk we
actually haven't said
anything about nouns okay so but it just
knew
to chunk these together right so that's
good
uh we did chunk this too we don't really
want that
and that there so we can probably get
rid of that um
this other stuff i'm not really sure
it's the best organization here
but it worked regardless
i'm actually pretty happy with this uh
little [ __ ] here for uh getting some
good down phrases in for us actually
uh but you know then you might add some
stuff like two or something like that to
it but for the most part
uh checking is pretty simple once you
get chunky it's not really too much to
add to it let's just do
that let's see if that gets us anything
better and let's do five colon i think
that'll start us off where we want to be
almost right invited to there we go
uh return i'm not sure
i'm is being called a prp
which is not preposition it's that
personal pronoun i think
i wonder i guess that separates that
actually because i
and then am humbled okay so that's why
they're doing that anyways
um so that's thinking there's not really
too much more to
say about it really again it's just it
can be kind of confusing with the
regular expressions if you're not
familiar with them but
if you get comfortable with those their
regular expressions are useful
for a lot more than just nltk so
it's definitely worth it's definitely
worth learning them if you
uh if you have the time to sit down so
anyways that's chine
chinking the next tutorial video is
going to be talking about
named entity recognition so you can
chunk to find noun phrases or just nouns
even
and think oh this is talking about that
or
whatever but you're going to find that
you're going to have some problems with
that
when it comes to as we've actually
already seen
let's say united states of america
president george w bush
it's not actually keeping them together
like george bush it's not keeping those
two names together it's treating them as
two different ones it's
correctly classifying as nouns but it's
not keeping them together so you can use
chunks to keep them together
but you can also use named entity
recognition to keep them together
sometimes this is pretty useful from
nltk
but also this is one of the weaker kind
of tools that nltk offers in my opinion
as far as
you know power and actual functionality
of it it could be really powerful
but it's obviously a huge challenge but
it's still pretty cool especially
because it can recognize the difference
between things like
uh numbers like amounts of dollars a
location
name stuff like that it's pretty cool uh
but it misses a lot of times especially
with names and stuff like that but
anyway that's what you guys have to look
forward to if you have any questions or
comments
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until
next time